can we talk real estate for a second
yeah let's do so
we were talking during the break about
just even in nashville it's just
it's crazy right now like our friends
are trying to buy houses and they're
asking like insane
over asking price and they're still not
getting it like it's just wild so
kovit plays into this and i know real
estate you know you look over
decades and decades you see the influx
of things going up and down i mean it's
just like
anything else but what do you i mean it
just feels like it's insane right now
and i don't know if that's just because
we live in nashville and nationally
it's so so what does covid
cause people because i would think
coming out of 2020 you almost are more
conservative and you're holding tight
and you're staying put because it still
feels a little unstable right like we're
not even i feel like out of
all the stuff with covid so why
why the like why the surge well several
things but
the baseline on it is there's a shortage
on new housing
because the lumber factory shut down
and a lot of the other components of the
house the factories shut down yeah new
lumbers just
say get lumber yeah and then when you
can't get it it drove the prices way up
on that
yeah and uh then there starts to be a
frenzy
around it a feeding frenzy like piranhas
you know it's like crazy
and uh and and so the new housing
slowed to nothing and there's this gap
of six or eight months of production of
the components therefore the new houses
and when you take the new housing gap
uh supply out the inventory supply out
then it shortens up the
well i can't get a new house so i gotta
go buy a used house and so it doubles
doubles down
twice many people looking at half the
numbers of houses and so you end up with
a
inventory shortage of new and used
housing
and a shortage always cause when you got
you know half the number of houses for
sale as there are buyers out there
you know two to one three to one ratio
whatever four to one whatever the ratio
is
then you know that just that alone did
this but the coke
what covete did was it shut down not the
real estate market because people were
still buying houses during quarantine
they were buying them sight unseen on
zoom and other stuff right right
but but the uh uh the factory shutting
down
the supply chain getting screwed up has
screwed up the economy
so it's not that there's more buyers
it's just that the well and then the
buyers go crazy
yeah and then the sellers go crazy yeah
and then the buyers go crazier
and so there's this this cycle of just
this feeding
frenzy and it's all in motion and and so
you know you're seeing properties
uh in lots of towns get multiple
multiple offers
uh you know fifty a hundred thousand
dollars over asking for yes yeah
and they line up through the whole
weekend and there's 62 offers on our
house over the weekend that's not
unusual in a lot of cities right now
but that'll subside it'll just
eventually the feeding frenzy calms down
and then they'll just be this like
hangover uh you know
like the housing hangover after that
will just be like
like the morning you've felt this ever i
mean for four years i've never seen it
like this
exactly yeah but uh in 19 in the 19
uh what we are going to see out of this
that you've never seen your generation
has ever seen is inflation
inflation the components that make up
the inflation index
housing is one of them it's the biggest
part of inflation
and when housing shoots up and oil
shoots up
and oil has shot up too yeah it has yeah
and uh you know
you look at the gas pump oh i know i
filled up my minivan two days ago
nobody's talking about it but the gas
pump doubles and housing goes up a bunch
then all of a sudden you're going to see
stuff like i saw in the 70s and 80s
which was double-digit inflation where
stuff's going up 10 15 a year
and inflation was out of control and the
politicians it took
it you know it took some real strong
politicians to do away with it uh it was
out of control how do they do away with
it
well i i credit ronald reagan i'm just
putting the brakes on because it was out
of control under carter and he comes in
and
shifted economic policy and uh just
started
opening up uh doing away with regulation
opening up the markets
because if you can flood the market with
supply
it slows down as flows down the feeding
frenzy because if you can get it
everywhere
there's no scarcity sure then the prices
start to settle
you know if there's an oversupply prices
go down if there's an under supply
prices go up
because there's people chasing it sure
demand you know if you you know half the
number of people chasing it as there are
you know you got two houses for sale for
every buyer
well all of a sudden prices stabilize
start to go down start to
or at least quit shooting through the
roof so the out of control
upward inflation so we're probably going
to see some actual inflation out of this
which we've not seen in two decades
but in 1982 or yeah in
1980s under carter the uh interest rates
on housing
was 18 17 percent i was in in college so
on real estate so guess what happened
nobody's buying houses
because your interest rate on a house is
like a credit card that's insane yeah
and so nobody's buying houses they're
all on the sideline going i can't buy a
house with these interest rates
yep and so everybody that would have
bought a house that year
starts stacking up and you get pent-up
demand water behind the dam it's getting
spilled over the dam and so when rates
came down
from 18 to 14
i was selling real estate at 22 years
old
and rates were 14 and there were cars
lined up around the block in the new
subdivision
it was like just that four percent i
mean like yeah but but it was three
four years of nobody buying a house and
the floodgates broke loose 14 was enough
to get them out of their house yeah
and it was like covey they lined up
around the dadgum block buying these
houses
and guess what prices went up interest
rates continued to go on down
yeah of course over the years after that
we saw 12 and then we saw
10 and i was on the radio by then and
i'm like oh you'll never see
single-digit interest rates again ever
in mortgages
well obviously i was an idiot and didn't
know what i was talking about because
we've had single-digit interest rates
and now we've got what we've had for
a decade we've had two or three percent
i was going to say it's like went down
last year yeah you watch these interests
that's the other thing you watch these
interest rates go up with inflation yeah
it'll shut this housing market down i
was going to say how yeah the
correlation between inflation and the
interest if you go from three to six
this housing market will freeze like a
deer in the headlights it'll just stop
people just stop buying they'll just
back up and wait
and uh that's you're gonna see some of
that back and forth now it's gonna be a
little rocky a little volatile but it
won't
this feeding frenzy that you've got
right this second is not going to
continue
yeah but you do not want to be buying a
house or selling a house right now
without a pro in your corner
oh sure this is not this is not amateur
hour yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah really not
amateurish
just a bizarre this is how you can
overpay for something or
or you know not get them you could you
could be off a hundred grand on what you
could have got
with an agent that knew how to
manipulate the whole process yeah
because it's basically a freaking
auction in some of these cities on some
of these properties that was one of ours
in our neighborhood
the builder did an auction he was like
highest price
and people were like i mean it was like
it was put them out in the front yard
crazy i was like
what is happening right now yeah yeah
without that but that's that it's i
don't know if it's just nap yeah but
it's an emotional frenzy
well that's it too buying a home if you
just back up and go
right now i'm just gonna chill and watch
all these crazy people finish
and when they finish then i'm gonna walk
back in there because you can't get a
deal
in most markets and the uh let's have
let's add one more variable to it
all the people leaving california
because they're sick of it they're done
they're done with crazy land all the
people leaving new york
because they're done with crazy land and
they're they're coming out they're like
oh there you go you can't get chicago
here's another short here's another
shortage
u-hauls u-haul's leaving california you
can't find one
you can't find them to rent one you mean
you can't really you can't rent one in
new york
because they're leaving they're all
leaving and they're not coming back